[Applause]
Cary's test here is test signal if you
can hear my voice signal if you can hear
my voice
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
behind me is the landscape of modern
Prague and it seems to me Prague is a
city which participated in one of the
most important bifurcations in the
history of Western thought a little
background may be necessary the emperor
rudolf ii was chosen by the electors of
the Northern League and at his death
they chose from among themselves a new
emperor in this case Frederick Prince
palutena
idle bird who had recently married
Elizabeth the daughter of James of
England Frederick the elector assumed
that the King of England giving his
daughter's hand in marriage signaled
approval for Frederick's visionary plan
for an alchemical kingdom in Central
Europe to be ruled by himself from
Prague and to this end Frederick
transferred his court from Heidelberg to
Prague in the fall of 1619 this is a
historical episode that has become known
as the incident of the winter king and
queen Frederick the elector Palatine of
Bohemia and his Queen Elizabeth ruled
for nearly a year from Prague and
brought with them the alchemists of
heidelberg personalities such as michael
maier johannes Andre and Heinrich Kuhn
Rath graced their Court
but the alchemical fantasies of
Frederick the elector Palatine of
Bohemia and his queen were destined to
fail for by the early spring of 1620 a
local bishop has raised an army and had
been joined by Habsburg troops who laid
siege to Prague and that siege after a
number of weeks succeeded among those
taking part in the siege was a young
French soldier who had been wenching and
travelling across Europe in the style of
the times Rene Descartes destined to be
the founder of modern scientific
materialism I like to think that perhaps
decart actually encountered his bet naw
Michael Maier Prince of alchemists in
the confused situation that prevailed
when Prague fell for Meyer was lost in
the siege of Prague never to be heard
from again
it's instances like this in the history
of European thought that have inspired a
group of American thinkers to form the
Bohemian Institute of Prague a
think-tank theatre group and video
production centre to be established here
in Prague and to celebrate the occult
and spiritual heritage of this great
city a city which had its alchemical
visions been completed modernity would
have been a far different affair
Tarrance Mickey well Terrence turns what
if there had been a different story what
if in the duel between - wire and
Grenada card that you have envisaged
it's not Meier who dies but Meyer who
blows the near fatal hits to Descartes
and Descartes experiences and near-death
experience in which she sees not only in
a panoramic view as we all know what
happened to the near-death experience
his own life but he experiences his own
future in the future of the world that
would have happened if his principles
his ideas his influence on the
scientific mechanical world would have
been as big as we imagined it has been
on the point where we're sitting now are
you saying we're trapped inside Rene
Descartes
near-death experience making you're dead
right in the near-death experience all
these characters myself and you included
we are just actress inside the cards
brain and as we all know near-death
experiences show in near-death
experiences a lot of tryptamine shows up
in the brain so I believe we are just
part of a trip to Maine near-death trip
of Rene Descartes in the year 1600 and
20 no there is of course an itch to it
yes right okay
now at a certain point maybe through the
ingestion of tryptamine compounds in our
brains become aware of the fact that
this is not reality but this is the in
the interior design of Day cards
near-death experience so we may become
aware of this well if he's just
imagining this as things could have been
but as they also may not happen well
what if we return come to life with Rene
Descartes
I mean we're bleeding all over the place
Michael Mayer is kind enough to nurture
the card back to health and in fact
decart and Mayer strike this interesting
relationship where one learns from the
other and I mean there's been a lot of
Descartes bashing in the kind of
transpersonal movement so what if the
card had really something to contribute
and what if what he had to contribute
would really well fit together with the
alchemical quest except now it's got a
different framework and so as we come
back Descartes is coming back to life
cooperating with Michael Mayer they then
have a chance to really rewrite history
at this point of bifurcation and rewrite
it in such a way that if we we're on
this parallel string of events we could
now look back and say well what if the
thirty year war had actually happened
putting us in a position where it never
happens now why did it not happen
my suggestion is Descartes fell in love
with a woman here maybe it was the
daughter of Robbie Luthor
and instead of having this 30-year war
between two denominations of the
Christian faith in their atavistic
patriarch or women debating way I could
imagine that instead you have a black
goddess cult developing instead where
the icon of the sacred marriage of women
and of woman and man becomes the icon of
a spiritual practice center of which
becomes the black Lady of Loretto now we
have a Loretto Chapel here or Loretto
Church here in Prague which is very
beautiful and so we could imagine the
string of history as it departs from the
way we thought we know it where the
papacy becomes more and more coated and
insignificant and the Pope just sort of
bling guru who's walking down the
streets of Rome whereas the spiritual
power shifts to this female black
goddess worship may be with a female
Pope right here in Prague
now as this unrolls of course all that
needed to happen to make to get us into
our predicament would has taken a
different course we would have had
alchemical modernity a project whose
time has definitely come probably by the
beginning of the or the end of the 18th
century we would have been able to
travel to the moon and have a sacred
marriage somewhere in space based on not
the exploitation of nature but of the
modern or chemical cooperation between
mind spirits and matter so all of this
is to say as we are awaiting from Dick
Hart's nightmare and as Descartes
himself awakes from his own night we may
be at a point where it's where we are
well advised to think of well what do we
need if the good ideas of alchemy
modernity spiritual marriage feminine
culture partnership versions of history
if they were no longer just an occult
underground bohemian dream but if they
were the ingredients of a mainstream
civilization that decides to take a
different course than the one we find
ourselves in right now well that's your
wound up on this I can tell it's
certainly an interesting idea I mean
it's not clear to me how closely linked
the evolution of modern science and the
Wars of Religion that the thirty years
war represented were I mean some people
might say had there been no thirty years
war there still would have been
there still would have been a Copernicus
but I suspect that you're probably right
that the 30 Years War somehow exhausted
the medieval eschatology and people were
then ready for new forms of governments
new forms of social order one of the
reasons that I'm so keen to establish
the Bohemian Institute here in Prague is
because you you really put your finger
on it I have the feeling that this is a
kind of more than simply a city but a
kind of dimensional portal or Nexus and
that many different futures beckon off
the Prague Nexus I mean we had the
potential democracy of young Margaret in
the twenties the communist period which
now appears like a dream it's like it
never happened so this seems to be a
city where historicity and dream easily
change places and many strange
appearances and cigarettes show up in
this dream you hear them coming
right and left well the Prague was the
European Jerusalem and maybe so again
because I think what Prague really
represented was the an equal sensitivity
to spirit and matter that what alchemy
meant was the union of spirit and matter
and the secular chemistry that arose out
of car team
thinking was just thoroughly
materialistic so you're right
the kinds of speculations that you're
indulging in would be precisely the
kinds of concerns that the Bohemian
Institute would concern itself with
because I think when we come back and
stand in these historically pivotal
places then with sufficient vision and
imagination we can probably send history
careening off in a slightly different
direction all right well then let's kiss
the sleeping beauty awake hey I'm all
for it I would love to see the progress
on state please okay here's to it
alchemy is a ancient art one of the
magical arts associated with dying and
the gilding of metals and tracing its
origins back to ancient Egypt but it's
modern culmination is here in the city
of Prague where in the 16th century
under the patronage of the Emperor
Rudolph the great alchemists of Europe
gathered and pursued their art including
Kepler alchemy is more than a technique
for the conversion of base metals into
gold it is the culminating metaphor in
the search for a union of spirit and
matter and whether or not this union was
ever achieved is as mysterious as much
of the rest of this ancient city but
whatever the success of the alchemists
they provide us with a metaphor for
spiritual transformation that is
extraordinarily applicable in the modern
era it was for this reason that the
Swiss psychologist Carl Jung
made alchemical motifs as important a
part of his theory of the unconscious as
the contents of dreams or folklore you
see before modern science the separation
between observer and observed was more
naively understood than in our own world
and the alchemists staring into the
swirling content of his retorts and his
alembics was seeing in his own
imagination not the processes of natural
chemistry but an intermingling of
psychological processes and material
processes in a domain of epistemic
confusion that we have grown distant
from nevertheless the legacy of our own
science is one of pollution of the earth
toxification of the oceans something has
been lost from the Western vision of
nature by the exclusion of the notion of
spirit and it's fitting that in an
effort to recapture that lost something
we returned to Prague the center of
European knock-out thinking and
beacon to any future thinking on these
matters
that star
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
dot start okay
I don't know it's a lot you could say
that wasn't said there that's for sure